ERIK ERNST: So my
name is Erik Ernst,
and I'm a member
of the Dart team.
And I'm located in Aarhus.
And we are working
on various tools,
including the dart2js compiler.
And you may have
noticed that there's
an issue about the size.
So space-frugal reflection
is reflection where it
doesn't take up so much space.
So that's the reason why you
might want to stay around
to listen to this talk.
If you've had this
conflict that you
want to have dynamic
code-- for instance,
if you want to
invoke a method, you
don't want to decide
upfront at compile time
exactly what the name of
the method is-- in that case
you need to use reflection.
And if you do that,
and you're not careful,
you'll have a size explosion.
So, in particular, this
happens in any platform
where you're using a compiler
that needs to do tree shaking.
But it's commonly
seen with dart2js.
So it's a problem
that's inherent.
It's basically an issue that
you don't know exactly what is
going to be used reflectively.
And this is an
undecidable a problem,
so you can't really hope to
remove the problem totally,
but you can give
programmers a better tool
to tell the system what
is going to be used.
So we're writing this
new package, Reflectable.
And Reflectable would give you
essentially the same interface
as what you already
know with Dart:mirrors.
And we have made
some small updates,
because we think that's
useful for the API as such.
It's not because it's
motivated technically
by the implementation.
So essentially the
same interface,
but you don't get
this size explosion.
So how does it work?
Reflectable has a foundation,
and the basic idea which
is associated with metadata.
So you have @-something on the
classes where you want to use
reflection.
So you would declare
reflection using metadata,
and then you'd also specify
which piece of metadata
you want to use to
get the reflection.
So you can see in the code here
that we want to use reflection
with the class C.
So we have created
this myReflectable
object, which contains
a specification of a
certain level of support
for reflection.
And then you'd use that to
indicate that the class is
included in support
for reflection,
and also to say that
this is the place where
we go to find the
reflect operation to get
a reflected version of
this particular object,
and that is a mirror.
So this is just to show you, for
once, this is the kind of code
that you'll see.
I'm going to go back
to similar examples
later on to explain how
this works in more detail.
So the idea was conceived
by Florian Loitsch.
You already know him.
You may have seen
a public document
that's called MirrorTags or
that talks about MirrorTags.
Now we've renamed
it to Reflectable,
because nobody liked the word
"tag" that kept turning up
in the API in different places.
So now it's called Reflectable.
That's far too
long, so you're not
going to put it in unsuspecting
places in your identifiers.
And Reflectable is about
where you can do reflection.
Currently, I'm
working on it, Sigurd
has been helping me
the past few weeks.
So it's a project that's
not particularly large,
but we're making
a lot of progress
right now, because we have sort
of got the foundation in place.
And we are now implementing
the actual API.
If you want to
take a look at it,
it's available at this location.
It is able to run the examples
that I show you today,
but there's a lot of
work to do on this still.
So, the basic concepts.
I just want to give you
the basic concepts such
that we know that we're
talking about the same things
with the same words.
So, in particular,
reflection as a concept
has got to do with the ability
of code to work on other code
as data.
So this makes it possible to
create new program elements
and to modify your
program in arbitrary ways.
So that's basically
the old LISP idea
where you'd work on your
program in a programmatic way.
Now, if you restrict this
to only introspection,
so that means you can take
a look at your program
to investigate what
are the classes
around for this
particular object, what
is the class of this object,
and, for this particular class,
what are the declarations.
And that's one part.
And the other part
is runtiming--
that is, taking something which
is usually a static expression,
like x.y, then the y is
a compile-time constant
identifier.
If you want to make the choice
of which feature to use,
which method to call, or so-- if
you want to do that at runtime
using a computed
value, then that
is what I call runtiming here.
So these two things are
at the core of reflection.
I guess this is
totally well known,
but I wanted to make
sure that nobody would
be in doubt of what it means.
So here's standard code.
I'm using Ruby code
here to show you
something that contains
kind of an error
that we don't have
been Dart, then
I'll return to Dart
code in the next slide.
If you do something without
reflection-- that could be,
you know, we have
a Lottery class,
we create a new instance
of that Lottery,
and we have this convenient
method called "win,"
so we're going to
win the lottery.
If you want to do that in
a way that's more flexible,
then you would specify the
class name as a runtime value--
something you compute.
It could be arbitrary
computation involved.
Here you have the :win symbol.
A symbol would be a string
that is better with respect
to its runtime performance.
It could be canonicalized,
it could be minified--
there are various things.
But basically, it's a string.
And then you could achieve
the same thing as we had here.
You'd create a new
instance, but now it's
not a compile-time constant.
It is a runtime expression.
So we would get an
instance of that class.
And we do that by sending
the new message to it.
And then here, we
can do object.send,
and that is a message that
is the generic reflector
message that will enable us
to call a particular method,
including that one.
So this is reflection
in the basic sense.
The next step is that
Gilad Bracha and David
Ungar argued in an OOPSLA
paper about 11 years ago
that it's a bad idea to
wrap up reflection together
with the base objects.
So the good design--
lots of reasons
for that in that
paper-- the good design
is to separate them.
So we want to have
a separate system
for providing reflection,
and we do that using mirrors.
So a mirror is an object that
plays a role as a proxy that
will allow you to
perform reflective
operations on the target
object, on the reflectee
of that particular mirror.
So, with that, you can have
multiple mirror systems.
That means that you can decide
on what kind of mirror system
you would have.
And the traditional
examples would be things
like, oh, this is for run time.
Here's another one for
investigating source code.
Here's a third one
for remote debugging,
for somebody else who's
running on a different machine
somewhere.
In this case, we want to
have multiple mirror system
because that will enable
you to tailor them.
If you want to have a lot
of support for reflection
with a few classes,
and then there
are lots of classes
where you want
to have more
lightweight support,
then you can tailor your system
in a very detailed manner.
So here we have Dart code
doing a similar thing
as what you just saw in Ruby.
And the difference
here is that you're not
using a method on
the object itself
that says something
like obj.send.
Here, we are working
on the mirror
to get the reflective operation.
And other than that,
it's just the same thing
that you have already seen.
So there's one concept here
which is kind of a detour,
but it also illustrates
the underlying issues.
Why do programs get so large
when you translate them
with dart2js, and
you're not careful,
and you're using reflection?
So the problem is that you
need to preserve information
about the program
also at runtime.
And minification
shows very clearly why
that will make a difference.
So minification is
known from JavaScript,
and it's also a well-established
concept elsewhere,
but it's also used
in Dart with dart2js.
We're doing this automatic
renaming to take long names
and transform them to the
shortest possible names that
are distinct.
And we don't care about
how readable they are.
So we have these long
names, and they disappear
during the minification phase.
And then we only have
these short names.
So my long readable
name becomes "xj7,"
and then if you look
at the running program,
it's actually going
to do "xj7" where you
had this nicely-named method.
Now, if you have a class that
implements no such method,
because you want to be able
to handle the situation where
somebody calls a method on
this object that doesn't exist,
then this guy's called.
And then we can
subject that invocation
to special treatment.
So we take the invocation,
and we investigate,
what were they trying to call?
Oh, they were trying to
call this foo37 method.
So let's compute something.
And that is an entirely dynamic
thing here, the expression.
And then we decide on whether
that's what they're calling,
so maybe we'll compute foo37.
And then that's going to give
rise to some behavior here.
And then we can return
the result here.
And people will think, oh,
this guy implements foo37.
Now, that's used
in a lot of places.
And in this case
here, you can see
that we have a new symbol and
a runtime expression here,
and we're comparing to the
member name, which is a symbol.
And that symbol
has been minified.
So now we have a nice long name,
and we're comparing to xj7.
So we can't answer whether
they are equal to each other,
because we have to know
the original readable
version of that name in
order to be able to determine
whether it's the same name.
Because the programmer
could never predict that
this would become xj7.
That's just going to be
this long readable name.
So we have to
preserve the mapping
from all those short names
to all those long names,
or the other way
around, or both ways,
in order to be able
to implement this.
So this guy is expensive.
And there's no limit
to the set of symbols
that you need to keep
around in order to do this.
So this is a good
example why you
don't want to use
a new symbol if you
can use a const symbol instead.
And it's also a good example
of the kind of effect
that makes programs so large.
OK.
So what is the new approach that
we're taking to Dart reflection
using this new package?
First, I'll just return to the
existing reflection system.
It's a very nice system for
reflection that's called
dart:mirrors.
It has a very compact
representation at runtime
at the JavaScript level.
And you couldn't really expect
to make it much more compact
than that.
But still, what we've
seen in practice
is that when people
use this, they
get these humongous programs,
these large programs,
and they're really had not happy
about the space performance.
And the problem is that
it's hard to control
what is supported by the
reflective system using
the available mechanism, which
is this MirrorsUsed annotation.
So what we're doing
is, basically, we're
trying to take an entirely
different approach
to this in order to make
it possible for people
to control the
level of reflection
in a much more detailed manner.
OK.
So what we're doing with
this new Reflectable package
is that we provide the same API.
There are a couple
of tiny differences
where we wanted to make an
experiment with the API.
So, for instance, if you
call invoke in dart:mirros,
you get a mirror.
If you do this with Reflectable,
you get the actual object.
Now, the point is
that you wouldn't
want to create a lot
of mirrors and then
not use them for anything,
because you're just
looking up the reflectee and
then dropping the mirror.
So it seems to be OK to
return the object directly,
and it gives you
better performance.
And if you do want
the mirror, then you
can just recreate
it by saying reflect
to that particular object.
So, apart from tiny differences
like that, it's the same API.
That means you could just
take your existing code that
uses reflection, and you
adjust it in these tiny ways,
and then it'll work.
Manual process, but a
very lightweight one.
Then we have a transformer.
That's basically a compiler
that does whole-program analysis
and produces a program that
does not use reflection anymore.
So you have the
pre-transform code--
you can think of that
as development code--
and for the pre-transform
code, you will use the library
Reflectable, and Reflectable
will indirectly use the library
dart:mirrors.
So we're back to the
old system, and it's
going to take up a lot of space.
But maybe you don't care
at that point in time.
And then you transform
it, and the result
is that we're generating
static mirror classes.
And they contain
ordinary static code--
there's no use of
reflection at all.
The whole system doesn't
include dart:mirrors.
And at that point,
we have this code
that'll actually do the
same thing for you, but only
for the cases that
you've specified
that you want support for.
OK.
So what's this used for?
Well, anything that you're
doing that needs reflection--
if you have a good
case, then please
come forward and tell us.
And important
cases inside Google
is Polymer and Angular and
Serialization and Mustache,
so lots of cases-- anything
that uses reflection.
So the package itself-- how does
it look, and how do you use it?
You need to think
in two steps here,
because this about mirror
systems that you're tailoring
for your particular purpose.
So the first step is
to design a mirror
system that has the
suitable level of support
for reflection.
And how do you do that?
Well, we have this
ReflectCapability capability
class.
You could say that this is
a stupid class, because it
has no methods, it
has no state; it's
basically just the
identity saying, here's
a ReflectCapability subclass.
It could be
InvokeInstanceMembers;
it could be InvokeStaticMembers.
All kinds of capabilities.
And then you just
build expressions
by piling up these things,
building trees of these.
And you could consider
them basically
as the abstract syntax
tree for an expression.
So what we have
here is basically
a DSL, or a
domain-specific language,
that will allow you to specify
the level of reflection
that you want to have.
And then we tie that up
with a particular object
which is an instance of
the class Reflectable.
And I'll show you
how that happens.
So here we have the
core class Reflectable.
That's in a library-- that's
in the library Reflectable--
and you just include that.
Then you create your own
subclass, MyReflectable,
and you specify inside that
class how much support you
want to have for reflection.
So here we have the
Reflectable class,
and one of the
things it contains
is the capabilities, which is
a list of ReflectCapability--
that wouldn't fit here.
So you're giving an argument to
this one-argument constructor
in order to specify what
those capabilities are
supposed to be.
And you do that in a subclass
that has zero arguments.
So we have a fixed setup
here, because that makes
it easy to generate the code.
Because that
basically means that,
for this particular class,
there'll be one instance.
So we enforce this
singleton property simply
by saying it has
to look like this--
you have to have a constructor
that has zero arguments.
This is just because it's
easy to get started like that,
and then we can
generalize that later on,
and we can support some
more flexible schemes.
But right now, that's the
only thing you can do.
You have to have a class that
looks like this and that has
this single constructor
that has zero arguments
and passes these arguments
to the superclass.
So that means that
when we have this,
we just continue, just
moved it over here
and create a const,
an object, that
is the single instance
of that class.
And now we'll use that
the rest of the time.
So when you look
over your system,
and you decide that you want
to have that level of support
for reflection in
this particular class,
then you say @myReflectable
on that class.
And when you've done that in the
suitable places in your system,
then you have
annotated where you
want to have your reflection
in a way that is local,
it's bottom-up, and
it's quite flexible.
It's very easy to support
generalizations of this-- like,
if you choose to specify
that to myReflectable
applies not just for the class,
but for all the subclasses
or for all the
subtypes, it would
be very easy to
extend the capability
language to cover that case.
So we'll see what we need.
But right now, we're just going
for the very simple approach
where you put these
guys everywhere
you want to have reflection.
OK.
So here, again, we have
the myReflectable class,
and we have this win method.
And now we want
to call this such
that people can't see
statically that we're
calling the win method,
because that's sort of unfair.
So here we do that reflectively.
And the only difference
to what you've seen before
is that we take the object and
then we get a mirror for it.
And we do that by asking the
mirror system for its reflect
operation, whereas the standard
dart:mirror system would tell
you to use the reflect
operation at top level,
so basically you can only
get that specific version.
And then you invoke
methods using that mirror.
So that's how it looks
when you're using it.
And here are a couple of words
about the singleton-ness.
So what happens is that if you
have a subclass of Reflectable
that has zero arguments
in its constructor,
and it's just that
single constructor,
then we know how it's created.
So if you have a const instance,
because that instance has
been canonicalized, so if
you have two of them that
have the same
state, then you only
have one, because
it's canonicalized
into a single
instance and you just
get more pointers
to that one if you
think you create more of those.
That means that if we're
editing the code of that guy,
we'll edit the behavior.
So if I edit-- I think
this is the slide that's
best-- this one.
Right.
If we edit the
code of this class,
then we edit the
behavior of that object.
It's a one-to-one thing.
So that's what we
rely on currently.
And we'll have to
generate more classes
and invent new fresh
names and stuff.
So it's going to
be later, if you
want to have a more
flexible approach to that.
So here's an example of
some actual running code.
So this is just a prototype
implementation of this win.
Of course, if you do have an
actual working implementation
of that, we'd like
to hear about that,
and you can send that by
private encrypted email.
Otherwise, we just
use this method here,
and the structure
of the whole program
is as what you've
seen until now.
So what happens if we take
this static program and make it
reflective using dart:mirrors
and no special precautions?
Well, it's just the extension
that you've seen before.
We get the same
expression down here
that you've seen several times.
So let's just note
that you can do this.
If you want to be
more careful, you
can add this
MirrorsUsed annotation.
So that's here.
And, in particular, one
of things you can say
is that the targets are foo and
that means-- oh, sorry, that's
going to be Lottery here.
So the target is Lottery.
And that means that
you're only going
to use reflection on this
particular Lottery class.
And that means that you can
generate much more tight code.
You don't have to have as much
information about the program
preserved as you would
have if you're just
using the reflection in
an unrestricted manner.
If you want to use
Reflectable, you
have to work a
little bit harder,
because you have to specify
the level of support.
So the way we do
that is by creating
this subclass, myReflectable,
of Reflectable.
It has this zero-argument
constructor,
and it passes this
argument to the superclass,
and it basically says, we
want to invoke members,
and that's all we
want to do here.
And then we have
this const again.
So what happens?
Well, what happens
is that if you're
using the non-reflective code,
it takes up like 9.6 kilobytes.
If you're just
using dot:mirrors,
it's like 170 times bigger.
So this is what
people have seen.
If you're very careful
with MirrorsUsed,
you could get that down
like 16 times to 100k.
And if you use Reflectable
right now, you would go to 78k.
So, basically,
this shows that you
have to be very
careful about this,
and we hope that we will give
you a much more flexible path
to specify the level of support
for reflection that you want.
And definitely you
wouldn't want to pay
that unless it doesn't matter
how much space programs take
up.
OK, so the implementation--
we have libraries,
and we have a transformer.
And the libraries
work immediately.
But if you want to have the
benefits of this package,
basically you need to
run to transformer,
and that's going to
be an in an integrated
part of the pub build.
And that basically
means that you
would specify that
you're using Reflectable,
and you're using
the transformer.
And then you're just
running pub build,
and then automatically
your program is going to be
transformed in the ways
I described such that it
doesn't use dart:mirrors.
For that, you will have to
use an import of Reflectable.
And you're not going to use
dot:mirrors in other ways,
because in that case you're
just undoing all the work that
we've been doing here.
So with it supports
invoke currently.
invokeGetter and invokeSetter
are the new names for getField
and setField.
That's one of those
little experiments
we're doing with the API.
They're going to be very
easy and very similar.
Code browsing requires
a lot more code,
so getting a class mirror,
getting a method mirror,
looking at all the decorations
in the class-- all those things
haven't been written yet.
So it's not ready.
But if you want to fetch
the code right now,
you can at least play
around with invoke
and get an impression
about how this works.
So the basic idea
here is here is
that we want to create a balance
between dynamism and output
size.
There's the core
class Reflectable.
You would create
subclasses of Reflectable
and pass in the superconstructor
invocation, the value of type
list of ReflectCapability--
that specifies
how much support
for reflection you
want to get with this
particular mirror system.
And then, when you have
designed your mirror systems,
you go around and apply
them in your system,
and it's going to look very
much like dart:mirrors.
But you need to remember to
say myReflectable.reflect
in order to get started.
And, basically, that's it.
[APPLAUSE]